[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want
that's how r2d2 talks like yeah must be
good but dude you're Asian that's like
the bottom the talent range like yo-yo
Ma's crying right now don't do that
again you're making you're making a
little I should have been playing some
Mozart with this huh yeah yeah that was
my huh don't you play any musical
instruments gonna I play the piano you
still play yeah a little bit
oh my son just started learning how to
play yeah I'm trying to relate through
my kid no it's great but I play the
piano and then I put a little bit of a
guitar and then that's pretty much it
you know when you have air Asian parents
they make you do it
yep and I used to have this instructor
if you got a one not wrong she would
slam the lid onto your finger oh [ __ ]
shouldn't you know that buddy taught me
how to deal with pressure yeah and
stress yeah so I just sit really
practicing did it really did it really
or did it make you more anxious it mean
it worsened guys she was Russian the
white asian and yeah the white is like
and you can't [ __ ] with them because
they're good with knives you ever see
the movie Eastern Promises yeah it's a
vegan
there you go Morrison there was a scene
where there's but Russians and they were
stabbing each other's penises with
knives in the home I just remembered the
bathrooms yeah that one the spod the
small one yeah yeah are the other ones
that when you throw the knives and the
girl spinning on the wheel and and the
[ __ ] knives get around them yeah
there are those ones Oh what those are
yeah like a magician trick like in
America it could be a Russian a magician
it's a knife thing also if a Russian
hands you a beverage you don't drink it
why is it poison wait like in real life
or a movie I just don't do it in real
life yeah I don't do you know any
Russians would you like a drink would
you like to drink please
right yeah and I go no thank you I put
it right back right
they you must drink this right I go [ __ ]
you right and we go back and forth like
that like that right but I a bit bit
poisons don't affect me how do you know
because I've made on I'm immune to all I
know I know it will kill me still good
right it still gives me diarrhea to do
not that you can yeah yeah I'm not that
Amir knock doesn't talk so be they put
no immune to your [ __ ] Cal poison a
little bit yeah but Russians are on the
crazy people on their tough no I can
tell you read fighter grew up between my
wrestling bears yeah which guys watch
the recent viral video of that kid
fighting of bears that could be yeah
this could be a bee oh yeah that's it
how do you say it last night now saying
something like that and during that
fight Hong is like yeah actually grow up
wrestling bears and I'm not joking and
all of us in the house really wait is
eat okay yeah I was laughing it just
sounds so crazy but that's like yes GP
kid I say this the Bears in Russia are
like their dogs you're saying it's not a
wild bear he just you know but they did
just they're used to it yeah the bear
was chained and in the they were like
the same height khabib in the bear but
you know you go to like some different
countries thing and there's a poisonous
snake yeah but that's like that the
tourists about the snake but the locals
they already know how to deal with it
alright I think it's one of those kind
of situations yeah
that's true like if you come to my house
you know
kalila knows about the crystal wall yeah
now I know not to touch anything
yeah but we tell you that don't touch
the crystal wall
yeah yeah right you Mike you know you
might die so we're not showering you
just avoid having the showerhead ruin
the art like you just stay well it's
actually by the bathtub in he's the only
one that takes baths I shower
well let's separate the shower and the
bathtub are separate I just walk past it
every time to catch everyone up um
what's your art again come on come
careful comes and then it just dries and
there's like well he actually spreads it
- oh yeah you spread it yeah well we had
to catch the moth that was a different
video then with like we're talking about
out of context know what you said it
made me look like a creep know what's
the right way to say let's go right with
him making sure it's the right right he
took he took the you know his human
paint yeah so you know it's white oh
here human paint and he's like a Picasso
Picasso Picasso right he and he made his
masterpiece
hey fingers have to be together I don't
do it like this I yeah exactly it's fine
art my friend again what do you do with
the leftover oh I do this I do it right
I do a little lick right cuz you gotta
you know change because every time it
comes out as a different color almost
hey well first off what he has it's
blood residence I've never seen such a
small amount of come come out of it
there's no smearing it's like a it's
like a baby tiniest dollop but because
you it's like that's what it is I come
so much it's now like Visine drops I
know it's no projection - it's you it
just kind of cries it's like a single
you're dehydrated yeah yeah my penis is
crying you're not drinking enough water
is that what it is I don't know what it
is we have a theory that I think that
with age your dick becomes a little
leaky so I think he has a lot more
pre-cum and then when the final one
comes out he's just ran out of and it's
embarrassing what I'm making love
because you know I go you want it it's
common yeah yeah it only just one drop
oh you could've locked with the finger
he's the first guy where he's the first
guy I've never said no to for swallowing
like I would have been like yeah I'll
take that because it's so not daunting a
little just okay I'll take that yeah
yeah it's fairly you can taste it
it doesn't even hit the back of my
throat it doesn't even make it past my
nose all it dissolves it that's awesome
yeah it is in the mouth yeah but yeah
those are the guys I'm does it feel the
same like that since maybe when you were
younger it was a bigger load and now
that it's a small oh yeah it was a
marshmallow marshmallow would come out
yeah yeah the one easier to put it in
the fire with chocolate and graham
crackers it was delicious a solid
cylinder it's not evenly but I think as
you get older it just I don't know what
it is it's just kind of dilutes or
something I think that the feeling is
still the same though cuz you feel so
good yeah when people when someone like
dies of tetanus the final stages that
they go into like this full back arch he
does a back like fast it beautiful I do
you like convulses backwards I know yeah
and I'm making a little noise what's the
noise you make
[Applause]
like that yeah
but he's like fully like in a yoga and
that she's just watching me like this
this is my boyfriend
I can do better she could do that no no
no so we need jackoff do you also come
the same way still he still writes her
back and everything know just what's
when it's with her special and you know
you get more into it you know get more
into it but like you know yeah that's
real also I don't like because I do it
in the bathtub when she's sleeping yeah
I hear it every night I don't think you
got well you hear the water splash yeah
yeah that sounds like yeah but um so you
taste your own come over no I don't
every time I've noticed my own called
the [ __ ] quiz every time every time I
believe her more than you okay just say
this so even if I did do it it already
came inside my but it wasn't from my
inside yeah that's a why are you so
ashamed so using that logic would you
eat your own [ __ ] it's in your body
that's true that's really clever you can
but I have already yeah you try gorgeous
I'm saying you have have you know I've
never that's disgusting I can't drink
[ __ ] it just [ __ ] drink it you reach
for like 10 times already isn't trying
to reach for it 10 times just drink yeah
pizza don't [ __ ] oh let me say this okay
kids are watching all right they're not
watching this when they're older they're
older already it's a bit we have a more
mature demographic okay good good good
so I'm gonna explain it like 13 and 35
okay that's great thing is this okay in
my life I probably have you just don't
remember
yeah don't remember yeah
I mean I still cut my farts do you do
that cuppa you cup and smell cop
no I don't smell it what's this turning
thing what could you got to keep it in
you know because it's not solid right
it's air yeah
so you cup it like that right and then
you just quit and you go right in there
like that like a secret yeah yeah and
you go right there
what are you smelling for me yeah
totally okay
Oh what are you smelling for what I was
smelling for armed substance I'm
smelling for on foods that I smell beats
I didn't eat beets and then what do you
do with that information I just I
catalogue it in my mind yeah it's all it
take a checklist nice every day you know
if I smell like blood or something we'll
follow that note and then out maybe a
little Hospital or something it's my own
way of like see if I'm healthier no you
definitely make it in the world you
think I would yeah thank you what would
say something with are you in half a day
I took him hiking and I had to drive up
the hiking trail to pick him up cuz he
had like a hypoglycemic event and he
basically went into a coma on the hike
trail 10 minute hike I couldn't move
like I I'm gonna die so no but I'm gonna
say this okay I'm getting so old and I
can't move see that what see this right
here
you know that hurt just moving here yeah
just moving that hurt you probably just
needed sleep and drink water what is it
you would you in water waters a new
thing outside little Asian water is a I
got laser I know you got cross-eyed eyes
laser eyes I think there are opposite
sockets or something why you so against
water I love water dude but you always
mention water and we got a drink water
[ __ ] you wanna man water alright I love
water I mean yeah what I meant to say
you know just don't look at me right now
man I don't know what you're looking at
yeah I mean cuz it's like you know
that's that's Joanne he's looking at you
like this are you mad because you
compared you you guys we're brothers he
could be my son brothers our son the one
well what do you think brothers are you
think you could be my son
sound brothers if what would be more
believable if I say this is my son or
this is my brother brother brother riot
I think my older brother and it's so
funny because I'm glad you said that
because I honestly believe that you're
handsome look away no no I don't know I
just know when I look at you I go yes
there's a good-looking fella I got that
he's genetically good look at when I was
driving up here and he was he was like
with his like clown pants athletic clown
have my Under Armour parent yeah yeah
you know how they dip down like that
like a court jester and it was sitting
there right and he was like talking to
George right and I was driving with
Michael with my kalila and I was like
yes he's good good good case no I really
in my head I think that I think that
you're very good thank you
yeah I like I like this if you keep see
yourself in the mirror I think I'm
seeing like a younger my younger self
and I think to myself you know what
that's not bad because when I was his
age I I thought I was ugly
really that was depressed I would look
in the mirror ago yeah because you know
you get conditioned in America back in
the day especially you know hegemonic
you know that means not where they state
throws you the media throws what
handsome is a good condition to believe
that that's what handsome really is yeah
and so now there's so much you know so
much more diversity yeah that you you
know an Asian guy can get a white chick
in high school yeah that fact when I was
growing up it was nothing I mean if you
did they build a statue of you in
Bangkok like if I if in the 80s if you
hooked up with a white chick they would
like write books about you yeah but now
it's like a regular thing right yeah
yeah because it's changing but so when I
was his age I was younger yeah there
wasn't you know in media there wasn't
people that look like me so I always
looked in the mirror and I thought to
myself that I was ugly what I like
you're an inspiration for a lot of other
thank you so much because of you being
on media yeah like I'll read articles
and a lot of people shut you up oh thank
you so much yeah like a bluer enemy that
could just crush it with one hand you
know I'm not gonna do that
oh thank you but so you know and that's
why I love being with you guys because
you guys are the next generation we're
already old on you - yeah it's probably
generation after us yeah [ __ ] that
generation you're like aluminum I think
you guys are cool what I think I was
just talking because I think you guys
are cool too as well okay so don't [ __ ]
of them yeah yeah yeah I like the young
generation on as well who's that - me
too
Timothy Donatella Getty there's like two
more generations out there I think so it
moves fast
I don't know moves so fast yeah yeah but
you know what guys um you guys speak to
a group of people out there yeah and
they don't true so think about that I
mean they they speak - they speak you
know they their demographic as kids they
have no hair on their own that was
impressive you burped and you stoke up
the conversation ago thank you but you
have to imagine remember when I was
growing up there was no one there was a
pat morita mr. Miyagi should be Augie I
just found out he's our office now
comedian yeah yeah that's he was on
happy days before I was like wow yeah he
was yeah you know he used to go to UM
you know who Don Ho is yes tiny bubbles
yeah he's saying do tiny bubbles he was
like a Hawaiian lounge singer he was
huge back in the day and when Pat was in
Hawaii he'd go to every single one of
his shows yeah do you know why because
he would do one joke and then we get a
huge laugh and he would only go for that
one Joe so doc
would be playing and then in between
songs ago Pat Morita is here and people
would clap and he would say Pat please
stand up and Pat would say I am standing
and then we're gonna big laugh cuz he's
short
yeah and that's why you went every [ __ ]
oh yeah so you could tell that one job
so he could be the the the joke yeah
right right but you probably got laid
after that to every show like some girls
like I like that short term you so
easily back there huh there was another
guy named Johnny you know he was a
korean comedian out of the college right
and he's Korean and he they did a movie
called they call me Bruce back in the
day anyway there's this all Pat's
generation
yeah just Pat this is the eighties early
80s late 70s and he was a Comedy Store
comic and I saw a tape on him was it
good no just this off he would come in a
tuxedo
yeah onto a stage right and he would
stare at the audience for maybe like 30
seconds without saying anything
yeah you know the audience is you know
rumbling what's going on here right and
he would believe as he go ha oh no two
minute laugh just from head oh yeah just
from her at all so they had it pretty
easy that then Dan ethnic Asda said that
they just have to talk now with the
right jokes and be actually good you
know yeah we just had to be Asian and
it's funny yeah yeah but we were we were
being laughed at
right now they're laughing at our skills
our minds you know the way we deliver
jokes and one thing people still laugh
at me well you cuz you know but my point
is is that but my point though is is
that we have you know we have content we
we say things that people relate to yeah
and so we're not the butt of a joke you
know we are we're more human you know
and that's the most important at the
fart
you pushed entirely too hard for that
one I know but still it's fly out of
your butthole right there you smell in
the pork and shrimp dumplings no it's um
at this time of day it's always this
time of day you fart a regular basis I
synchronize my farts yeah yeah and you
lock it in carpet because you know
there's company you know who got to
smell the substance usually do i
catalogue that information yeah you know
what I apologize for even doing that
that's [ __ ] I'm not an apology
do you know why why if I didn't get up I
will hit the ceiling you know it has so
much projection I what is I would've I
could've died sorry or not I'm not I
thought yeah you know what in your face
it was in her face I know it's alright
little head it did sound you ripped your
underwear I'm sure you did its life you
know I was wet or you ever loose
butthole
it's one of the do you the prolapse you
know my butthole is very tight you know
how I know you know I know
no my poop looks like angel hair pasta
it's like gotta be the water like it's
like noodles are you squeezing as you're
pushing yeah yeah I squeeze it it's like
a nice noodle so what is the truth is
not my thumb goes up there all the time
her thumb goes up there all the time
it's only tight one direction here
pretty gaping yeah yeah one when it
comes out it's very tight when it comes
in is a loose goose loosey-goosey Here I
am
[Music]
you